[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like Brandon Shaw if you ain't
thick please don't get involved
now Brandon six boys
what is up there Monday December 12th it
is the morning here in Calabasas
California what's popping everybody good
uh for all you la folks out there don't
worry your car will not melt in the rain
so don't drive like it all right dude
stop driving like that let's tighten up
let's tighten up La little rain's not
gonna melt your car let's just drive
like normal took an hour get the kiddos
to school be cool be cool your boys come
in fresh off a busy weekend to Calabasas
fight campaigns Friday night was rough
and rowdy bar stool cow bass fight
companion
uh rough and rowdy 19 in Providence
Rhode Island and we had one heck of a
time I paired up um an unusual pair of
gentlemen for This Crew because Ruff and
Rowdy obviously it's not UFC specific so
um I lined up adam22 Rampage Jackson
Teddy swims and Donald cowboy Cerrone
um I mean Rampage is my boy me and
cowboy go way back Adam and I are boys
we're not that close though but
obviously he's a professional podcaster
he's one of the biggest in the game and
then Teddy swims is the voice of a thick
angel with tattoos on his face and uh
did he start drinking that tequila and
Teddy started just going Teddy was going
Teddy was going and the one takeaway
from that show is Rampage does not like
his butt played with that is a fact uh
it was a fun time and that uh you know
if you would have told me the rough and
rowdy card would have been better than
the main card in the UFC pay-per-view I
would have called you a liar but that
was the case that was the case the rough
and rowdy had more entertainment and was
more
fun quote unquote to watch than the main
card in the UFC
um
both companions were fun it's just
you're talking about pick your poison
you're talking about whiskey and Tequila
pick your poison they're both good but
uh whichever one you like and then
Saturday Night for UFC 282 I had the
great Sam Tripoli
um I have the obviously the my partner
in crime Brian the kid Callan and then
also
um a guy I've known forever too is uh
Frank Grillo who's a legit Straight Up
movie star so
um
you know it was it was just completely
different completely different Polar
Opposites both fun they're available
right now I'm thinking boy YouTube you
can watch the rough and rowdy bar stool
fight companion and then also the UFC
282 combat fight campaign and uh they're
both different they're both fun they're
available right now in thick boy and uh
it was just a fun week it's my favorite
show of all time to do so
um shout out to Joe Rogan for giving the
blessing to do that show because it's
one of the highlights of my life these
days so I had such a good time
um but let's get right into it
um I'm gonna break down rough and rowdy
all 20 fights just kidding just playing
fam obviously there's a lot of
controversy going on right now with the
UFC 282 for a variety of reasons but
this card seems to be overshadowed
um with the decision of Paddy pimlet
because he's a the most famous guy in
the card B
um the controversy of his unanimous
decision win over Jared Gordon
um and even that takes a over kind of
notoriety takes over
I mean especially in the in the
headlines over the light heavyweight
title fight over Yan blockovich and
magamed
you know because that was a draw and um
so right now if you look at the
the headlines the majority of us can be
Patty pimlet
um you know was gifted a decision over
Jared Gordon I do not align with that
and what I think before I get into that
the card was fantastic before the main
card the main card wasn't bad right so
we kinda
base a pay-per-view card off the main
event so when the main events like that
kind of takes this the wind out of the
sails of of the the hype machine ship so
a lot of people all the cards sucked I
don't I'm not going to go as far and say
it sucked because the first three fights
uh
you had finishes you had finishes and uh
du policies and Darren till was probably
Friday the night and then to kick off
the main card you had Bryce Mitchell and
toporia and taporia had a coming out
party had a coming out party and put it
on Bryce Mitchell Deborah was your
probably your MVP of the night there
taporia put his name in that hat and you
know he can hang with those top top
eight guys now you see the skill set on
toporia who's undefeated Bryce Mitchell
also undefeated
people tend to forget though and I don't
know why and I always thought about this
when I was a fighter too
they never I mean I could tell you
logistically why but you know Bryce
Mitchell was submitted on Ultimate
Fighter so he does have a loss on his
techno his resume that fight actually
happened but because the commission
those 522 rounds that's the way the UFC
gets out of you know the news getting
out so it ruins the show so by making it
two rounds it doesn't make it an
official fight so they don't have to
announce the results because it's the
official fight the results would be out
it ruined the show the ultimate fighters
especially back then
um they're worried about views and stuff
like that now not so much now they could
just do the thing right and always
really fall multiple fighter these days
um so well I've seen Bryce Mitchell lose
before and he came back and you know
went on a crazy streak and he became who
he is now this phenomenal Grappler and
so this isn't anything new for Bryce
Mitchell he's obviously going to have to
go back to the drawing board obviously
stand-up is an issue
you know
you'll hear a lot of experts say you
can't be you know dominant in one thing
these days in the UFC I completely
disagree with that you can be dominant
but you have to be a uh an outlier
dominant you have to be a khabib
dominant dominant you have to be a uh an
Izzy dominant and striking so it could
be in regards to grappling he's so
dominant he doesn't need to work on
anything else he's such an outlier he
doesn't have to work on a striking which
he did but to the majority of his wins
and by majority I mean all of them I've
seen Connor with the right hand because
no one expected but for the majority of
his entire career he was such an outlier
he's so far ahead of the game was so
dominant in grappling he could be uh
kind of one-sided Izzy too when it comes
to striking he's an outlier there and
then obviously things to catch up with
you with Bryce Mitchell he is definitely
a one percent when it comes to grappling
but his wrestling's not one percent and
as you get to the higher level it that's
going to tough if you're just a
specialist but you're not an outlier
specialist it's going to catch up with
you and it did on Saturday night against
saporia and we saw that was a dominant
dominant win by deporting that was his
coming out party with uh du policies and
Darren till I was rooting for Darren
till room for Darren till for a variety
of reasons I know it's like to go on a
losing streak not to lose streak he's on
but I know it's like to lose you know
two fights in a row and you think you
know you got to go back to your old ways
and you think by changing camps give me
this new thing and and Camp you're
dominating guys you're like I'm back and
they get in there and you're questioning
yourself it was at the right move and
there's only one way to find out it's
very black and white and how you look
inside that octagon and
it's not that didn't tell look bad and
that first round looked awful right that
first round like well this is genital's
gonna get caught he was getting Molly
whopped um he got beat up so bad that
duplicity's kind of wastes his gas tank
and credit kudos to Darren till and
because the training that's why I was
telling counts like that still doesn't
look in shape I'm like dude trust me
nobody trained harder on this entire
card than Darren till he is ready to go
when it comes to that that's one thing
you never have to worry about during
till being prepared his preparation is
almost too much the kid's gonna be ready
to go
and that showed in that second round and
it showed a little bit of
I don't say vintage Gentile because the
Vintage didn't tell the gorilla would
have starched duplicities in that second
round a guy who's on his back foot
looking like a jersey short you know
brawler he would have lit that dude up
and got him out of there Darren till
thing is mental it's all mental and he
he even alluded to it on his Instagram
he went live I think from the locker
room saying I don't know what is I trade
my ass off I'm a monster in training
I just can't pull the trigger that's all
mental sounds like he needs a mental
coach who knows I feel for the guy I'm
rooting for him
um it was five of the night uh I don't
think duplicity's in that first round he
looked like a world beater then after
that you know I it gets a little tough
for him
um but Darren Taylor should have got him
out there and stick around vintage
Darren till would have got him out of
there that's all I'm saying
umio ax Murano Morano had that fight
especially taking on that short notice
you can see when they read the decision
he goes I gave that fight away and he
did uh ponson new probably should have
won that fight
so let's get to the co-main event the
main event so with the Covenant event
with Patty pimblet and uh Jared Gordon
um
I told you guys on last week's show I
said this on the on the fight campaign
with Brian Collins Sam tripling Frank
Grillo that this is Patty pimlet's
toughest test and to me it was almost
too much too soon
because if you look at Patty and his
experience in the UFC
he's he's beating guys right he's
beating guys but he's getting hit and
you can see some holes in his game and
he has the personality and he has the
work ethic and he has the look he
checked every single box
but Patty currently as I'm sitting down
talking to you guys right now whether
you're on your driving to work or you
know you're at home with the kids or you
run around doing errands whatever you're
doing as you're listening this Patty
right now isn't a top 10 guy at 155.
he's just not as bad as you want him to
be he's not and I don't think Patty has
gone out and called out those top 10
guys you know but
um Patty is an exciting prospect and
unfortunately he's getting the same
treatment I hate to do this compare the
two because you know it is different
apples to oranges but it is the fight
game he's doing the same treatment that
Jake Paul is getting where when a guy
gets too much notoriety
it's in the DNA of MMA fans the DNA of
you know the inbreds or the the haters
on social media to bring those guys down
when you think it's not deserved there's
nothing that triggers people more
so even though I think Patty gets
everything that's coming his way and I
would argue that too with Jake Paul
for Patty you there seems to be this
narrative online I want you guys to pay
attention to the the headlines if you
look at the headlines right now it is
the cool thing to do to hate on Patty
pimlet the cool thing to do the thing
that's going to get you views the thing
that's going to get you clicks that and
even
some of the biggest MMA journalists in
the world are going to follow the same
protocol the move right now is to tear
down Patty pimlet I won't be part of it
there's no reason for it Patty doesn't
control the judges Patty can only
control what he can control and that is
fighting and Patty went out there and
gave his best effort and the three
judges that Patty has nothing to do with
decided that he won the fight whether
you think he should have won or not
Patty cannot control that that is not on
Paddy so instead of taking your hate out
on Patty pimlet even if you're a Jared
Gordon fan or you're just a Patty hater
your hatred should really go towards the
judging of the UFC that the problem is
not a Patty pimlet problem it's not a
yawn magomed problem it's a UFC problem
it's the judging it's the judging the
criteria based off an old model so the
common uh casual fan could understand is
based off of boxing
criteria and then they kind of
manipulate it so it works for MMA but it
didn't come from our own foundations you
know Big John McCartney did the rules
and stuff like that when it comes to the
judging that is based off an old school
criteria that's been around for damn
near over 100 years based off boxing so
the common fan could understand the
judging scoring these 10 nine rounds the
10-8 rounds right
but that's based off a very
it's not as simple when it comes to
boxing boxing is a sweet science and
obviously there's a lot that goes into
boxing but boxing is way more
easier to understand than mixed martial
arts and educating the fan base on mixed
martial arts because there's so much
that goes and makes martial arts it's
mixed martial arts boxing is one part of
that criteria yet you're using an old
dinosaur judging system that's kind of
manipulated to fit in so people can
understand the judging it makes no sense
but back to Patty I get to the judge in
a second back to Patty
let's take a little break for me
chatting here off about the fight game
because it is the season to clean your
balls my friends at manscaped are
helping you clear your driveway for safe
travels this holiday season from
stocking stuffers to white elephants
manscapes products are at the top of
every wish list grab some crop mops for
your pops with a body buffer for the
holiday lover when this year's white
elephant gift and help all the Bros in
your life go from eggnog to nice hog
this December and save 20 off and free
shipping by going to manscape.com
manscape is a One-Stop shop for all your
holiday needs they get the perfect gift
for all the men's in your life for your
grandmother hairy shoulders in the
mustache we're talking about that
Platinum package 4.0 it they have loads
of little presents that make the perfect
stocking stuffer all right that freaking
Platinum package 4.0 comes with the
lawnmower comes with the shares to clip
them toenails you also get got preserved
cologne the body buffer they got it all
man this is where else she gonna go
where else are you gonna go safe toward
himself and free shipping by going to
manscape.com that's right 20 south and
free shipping by going to manscaped.com
schab manscape for a perfect gift that
will be the holiday's biggest hit
manscaped this holiday season the best
deal in Wireless can only be found at
mint mobile right now when you switch to
Mint mobile buy any three month plan
you'll get another three months free as
the first company to sell premium
wireless service online only the cut out
the middleman mint mobile lets you order
and activate from home with a esim card
all right while saving tons on phone
plans started just 15 buckaroos I've
been using mint mobile long before this
holiday deal I have to say it's the
perfect gift all right you can buy three
months you get three months free it
makes a great gift maybe your kid after
16 17 years old he's been begging you
for a phone now's the cheapest this best
way to get it done mint Mobile's best
offer of the year is here for limit Time
by any three month plan get three more
months free that's six months what but
you only paying for three by going
online with the e-sam and eliminating
the traditional cost of retail mint
mobile passes significant savings onto
you all right all plans come with
unlimited talk and text high-speed data
delivered on nation's largest 5G Network
use your phone that you're currently
using with any mint Mobile plan and
switch easily it's so easy to do with
the e-sim card or if you need a new
device for a limit time you get six
months of free service when you buy a
select device and plan switch to Mint
mobile and get premium Wireless starting
at 15 buckaroos for limit Time by any
three month Mobile plan and get three
months free by going to mintmobile.com
schab that's mintmobile.com shop cut
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com shop this episode of
the shop Show Breaking Down Patty pimlet
all the controversy UFC 282 pay-per-view
is brought to you by my friends at Rogue
nicotine I love Rogue nicotine you guys
know this I use pouches every day I have
some in my mouth currently you see the
freaking cans on my desk everywhere I go
Rogue nictine is with me my favorite
flavors the Apple but you can get them
in all sorts of delicious flavors like
the Wintergreen the peppermint to Mango
the Citrus to Berry they got it all
that's why I chose them because their
flavor is intense and I can't get enough
Rogue also makes other great products
like gum tablets lodgingers I love that
you can take anywhere I want flights
comedy clubs no restrictions Rogue is my
go-to source for nicotine I absolutely
love it I asked them to be part of the
show because I use their product so much
if you want to try these pouches like me
or the gums or tablets everyone get your
nicotine go to roguenicketing.com use
promo code Rogue 20 for 20 off your
order that's 20 off your entire order
when you go to freaking
roguenicketing.com Rogue 20 for 20 stuff
your order all right underage sales
prohibited warning the product contains
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical for more information visit
roguenicketing.com
so again you're going to see in the
headlines and right now it's kind of the
Nickelback effect right somewhere along
the lines and people blame it on the uh
the movie with Seth Rogen 40 year old
virgin where he goes you know I know
you're gay listen to Nickelback and for
whatever reason that became a free pass
to hate on Nickelback now Nickelback is
a massive fan base you look up the
record sales obviously people like
Nickelback but online is different world
you know and the same goes from Machine
Gun Kelly
somewhere along the lines it was okay to
go at these guys and be really mean to
them and we all accepted it right it was
just something that
social media thought this is the guy to
go for let's go for him and try and tear
him down with Nickelback Patty pimlet
right now
and you're gonna see in the headlines
with some major Outlets that will try
and paint this narrative that Patty
maybe a bad guy or Patty's racist or
Patty this or Pat they will go for any
little [ __ ] in the arm to try to
devalue Patty pimlet any you're gonna
you're gonna see outrageous headlines
coming up you're gonna see you know
Jared Gordon was robbed and uh Patty
pimlet doesn't deserve this and this and
all this and you know Patty's the most
overrated fire of all time and he's the
next Sage Norris cut and when I see oh
he's next Ronda Rousey which that I
wouldn't get into that's so insane to
for comparison saying she's already it's
just honoreducated but
you're going to see this narrative that
it's okay to hate on Patty pimlet how
old is Patty 26.
I think Patty's 26.
27. so Patty is a 27 year old kid
he grew up
loving Diego Sanchez and Clay Guida on
Ultimate Fighter 9.
but the internet thinks it's a cool
thing to do to try to bring this kid
down and he has nothing to do with it he
is he goes out there he put his heart on
his sleeve he tried his best to beat
Jared Gordon what do you think he won or
lost doesn't really matter because we're
not judges and at the end of the day in
the record books and the way he goes in
the rankings it doesn't really matter
but you guys are so mad at Patty you're
so mad at Patty he has nothing to do
with that judging but again it's the
Nickelback
Bieber you know kind of effect where
somewhere along the lines it became the
cool thing to do to hate on Patty pimlin
I don't understand it I don't understand
it because when you look at this fight
again pay attention to the narratives in
the media in the way these journalists
and MMA Outlets because they know it's
gonna get clicks watch how toxic how
awful how evil it is the way they're
going to try to manipulate the system
and
sway you guys one way to be anti-patty I
will never understand it it's so it
breaks my heart a 27 year old kid who's
reached his dreams and his dreams become
a world champion the amount of hate that
is headed his way right now even a guy
in Suga which he's a little different
her Troll and do his stuff and he likes
that with Patty I'm telling you I've sat
down with you name it everybody Patty is
a sweet human being he's a good kid
who's trying his [ __ ] best and for
whatever reason something that he's
doing is triggering you guys maybe you
think he doesn't deserve it or whatever
it is it doesn't matter it does not
matter that does not warrant the type of
backlash that he's getting right now it
doesn't make sense to me
and when you talk about robberies let's
talk about Rob if the MMA media and the
MMA fan base will use this term he was
Rob Jared Gordon was robbed he was at
Rob the the anybody with uh educated eye
for mixed martial arts in the sport
could score this for Patty now do I
wholeheartedly think Patty won that
fight man it's tough him the first round
I guess he was the aggressor uh land
some shots
um his submission attempt even though it
wasn't really close especially on the
level the the level of uh Jiu Jitsu that
jiren Gordon is probably not that close
but still an attempt a dominant attempt
of finishing uh move to kind of end the
fight
um but you could there's argument give
Patty the first round second round
definitely argument you look at the the
compustrike numbers
I can see it I didn't see an argument
for Patty do I think he won the fight
get into the head tough tough tough but
do I think he was robbed dude I think
Jared Gordon was robbed or you're gonna
see in the headlines again until you see
this biggest robbery in UFC history
you know insane that is you have you
ever seen and now you're talking about a
life-changing decision you're seeing GSP
Johnny Hendricks
that would be a robbery a robbery would
be a guy who clearly beat the hell out
of the guy and they give the other guy a
10-8 round which they make no it makes
no sense uh a Canelo and Triple G would
be a robbery and there's some inside
work going on there there's things like
that that that's a robbery this is a
close fight where there are some
educated Minds out there who know the
game who could score it for Patty pimlet
and also the fan base can also go ah
it's a close fight if ever it's Up For
Debate there's a close round you don't
really know how to score maybe that
first round even though Patty's the
aggressor but Patty was getting hit with
that left hook he's taking bigger shots
but Patty's more active you can see how
the judges can kind of be swayed Patty's
way
to say to robbery again it's this
narrative and you see it's like the uh
the the kid in school if you've ever
seen Mean Girls you find one one week
link and then it becomes cool to tag to
tag team that kid and and Bully that kid
and get more people to do it everyone
everyone come on look at this look at
this kid this kid and for what
love to hear it for what why don't you
like them
what is it
love to hear it
love it doesn't really talk [ __ ] if the
guy talks [ __ ] he'll do his thing but
you know he's not polarizing he's not
saying awful hateful things it's the
fight game so two firestocks stuffed
each other that's fine if you're a fan
of Jared Gordon that's fine but this
just when this fight was a controversial
decision this opened up the floodgates
go all right now we have a reason to go
after this kid I just don't get it a 27
year old kid who's trying his best now
to that point
is Patty pimlin a top 10 guy no he's not
nor is he saying he is nor is his
management saying this is he asking for
a title shot no and if I'm the UFC
I look at Patty pillman's performance
and I from the jump thought oof don't
like this one not yet what's thrush well
the rush is is because he's such a big
figure in the in the UFC that they want
him they want to catapult him to the top
and him to be the face of the UFC and
you know European uh MMA especially in
the UFC is blowing up right now and we
haven't had a big face you know as big
as Leon Edwards is and some of these
other guys and Darren till Patty
pillman's more famous than those guys so
maybe that's what triggers you but you
know the UFC wants him to be that guy
but after watching the fight whether you
think he won or lost let's say the UFC
in the
on the same in the back in their meeting
today and they go how many people
thought Patty won even if every person
in that room during their marketing
meeting raises their hand
you have to look at that with a critical
eye and go he's not ready yet
he's not ready for the for the big boys
yet he has a lot of work to do
especially on the feet right and with
the grappling even though the submission
attempt was good with his wrestling
there's work to be done there and that's
okay that's okay that's also why Ed
Suarez who's one of the greatest man
managers of all time goes
do not come to the UFC unless you're
ready to be a top 10 guy unless you can
fight anybody and find a way to win in
the top ten there are no warm-up fights
in the UFC but here we are and we've
seen the UFC over time learn from the
mistakes where I do think they made a
mistake with Darren till who has all the
talent in the world but they push them
too fast too soon that was also a
British fighter they pushed him too fast
too soon put them in Woodland freaking
Liverpool and it's just all this
pressure on me gets knocked out and then
they keep throwing them monsters because
they thought he'd bounce back and he
hasn't and they've broke their toy they
they broke down until mentally and I
don't know if there's coming back from
that I don't know I hope so but he looks
like he's struggling with that
so they've learned from that and you see
what they're doing with sugar Shawn even
though his last fight against Peter Yan
I get it that was a huge step up did he
pass the test I would say even he
thought he lost that fight still showed
he's a top five guy but he had a lot
more warm-up fights than Patty has had
something you'll see I'm looking at that
you're going fight going we got to be
careful on the next fight we can't get
him top 15 guy hey whoever makes the
rankings don't put them in the top 15 I
don't think they will but you know there
is this pressure to throw these guys to
the freaking wolves
you know same thing with the the Jake
Paul I'd like to see him fight Canelo
he has six fights canel are you out of
your goddamn mind who in the world would
do that that makes sense but did we live
in this world where if a person's Fame
gets bigger than their ranking okay
you're more so Patty pill is more famous
than Leon Edwards or more famous than
this guy he needs to be fighting those
guys don't confuse Fame
with skill set Paddy's Fame has risen
more so than his skill set because of
who he is the the
all the suicide stuff the message he
puts out he's electric on camera he's
fantastic on camera he's a good person
and he does have a very good skill set
his grappling is fantastic but he's not
there yet so you guys are confusing a
lot of people out there especially the
media are confusing Fame with skill set
and it's okay that Patty's not there yet
he's young man he has a wow it's a
marathon not a Sprint but you guys want
to Sprint these guys to the top you
should have learned from the Darren till
fight when you sprint guys and they're
not ready you're gonna ruin that person
you're gonna ruin that fighter it's not
the way it should work
but again pay attention to the media
watch how mean and Savage and brutal
they are to a 27 year old kid who's
pursuing his dreams pay attention how
the media will sway this and manipulate
it and make you think that Patty pimlets
this awful overrated fighter remember
Patty didn't ask for all this you guys
gave it to him and now you're mad that
you gave it to him you gave him all this
attention and you're mad that he can't
fight the Charles Oliver's the Justin
gay cheese the mock Chefs of the world
you're mad but the same people are the
same people that gave him all this
notoriety and gave him these these
opportunities and gave them also a
platform to get massive and don't get it
twisted Fame Talent he's not there yet
will he get there yeah he will if they
take the necessary steps I truly believe
body can be a world champion he has the
mindset of it and I love that people
saying Patty's not ready for the big
show okay do your homework on Patty
pimlet he was selling out giant venues
in Liverpool on his own in cage Warriors
before he got to the UFC so that doesn't
work the kid shows up when the pressure
is on now
the Patty pimlet Jared Gordon fight was
more a factor of how damn good Jared
Gordon is and Patty Penman when he faced
an adversary and Jared Gordon who's very
skilled
Patty got a way that made what made
Patty special he stopped doing kind of
the unconventional stuff you know he
went back to just kind of striking he
would do some grappling but really he
got in the Striking battle which doesn't
Patty on the feed isn't special Patty
being unconventional
being hard to train for is what makes
Patty special so he got a little bit
away from that against Jared Gorham
because Jared Gordon's that damn good so
Kudos Jared Gordon and it was a close
fight and it probably should give the
nod that you're going but
there's nothing wrong with giving the
fight to Patty pimlet but again
watch how the media and these MMA
journalists will paint this picture on
how Patty's this awful person he's
overrated when you guys are the exact
same ones who gave him the platform so
his star could rise this big but you're
confusing notoriety and fame with skill
set You Gotta Give the kid time to get
there otherwise you're gonna miss out on
something special
you miss out on something special that's
the side we live in craps one tear
people down tear people down tear people
down won't be part of it wasn't a
robbery I've seen robberies that's not a
robbery shut up but again watch the MMA
Media Watch how nasty it's gonna get for
Patty pamlett I won't subscribe to it
he's a 27 year old kid
let's take another little break kids got
some ads for you because UFC don't stop
won't stop you gotta fight night this
Saturday you got Canon there versus my
boy Sean Strickland all right if you
want to bet on the fight should you do
it at one place one place only I'm
talking about DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner the UFC
this Saturday new customers can bet just
five dollars pre-fight money line on any
fighter to win and get 150 in free bets
if they do check this out right now
everyone can earn up to 50 boost when he
plays the same game parlay on this
Saturday's fight night but guess what
not only can you bet on UFC you got
World Cup popping you got the freaking
College Bowl series popping pick your
teams make some money with DraftKings
download the app use the promo code Shob
show Schaub show bet five dollars
pre-fight money line on any fire to win
this Saturday and get 150 in free bets
if they do that's code shop show this
Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner the UFC
minimum age eligible restrictions apply
C show notes for details last one then
we're back to the program this episode
of the shop show is also brought to you
by my friends at audit audit.com that's
right when you use audit.com well what
do we get you get 10 off the best
supplements on the planet you get 10 off
the best nootropic on the planet I'm
talking about Alpha Brain that's right
now sure you can go to Walmart and pick
it up but it can save ten percent and
get delivered to your door so you can
avoid going to Walmart and seeing the
warlocks there and get delivered to your
door and save ten percent by going to
audit.com you get the best nootropic on
the planet talking about Alpha Brain
over a million bottles sold and listen
if you don't like it
you're not send the product back keep
the product they refund your money
that's how positive they are you're
going to love the nootropic we're
talking about Alpha Brain over 1 million
bottles sold fire up your brain then
also get in shape don't wait till
freaking January 1st to start going oh
I'm gonna get in shape it's my year no
start right now save 10 off talking
about protein powder krill oil creatine
kettlebells steel Club Macy's streaming
Fitness we got it all there's no reason
to wait on it.com shop 10 off now let's
get back to the program
um and then the main event didn't help
and this shows you how big of a Star
Patty pimlet is because he's overshining
this
you know you had a draw for the fifth
time ever in a title fight you had a
draw with yon and magumed what's
interesting we had one with Murano and
um
why am I freaking his name Murano Hood
Murano face figurito he you know you had
it yeah Moreno yeah Moreno and figarito
you had to draw there right so that's
pretty recent
um
over the history of the title fights but
with yawn magomed I don't have a problem
with the draw I thought there's an
argument that Jan won the first three
rounds his leg kicks was doing the most
damage out of anything that was going on
in the fight I thought mogamed showed
his true colors in that fourth and fifth
round going all right on the feet I
thought I'd have a speed Advantage I
thought I'd be able to get off on him
it's not working let's do what got us to
the dance which is his grappling his
ground and pound his wrestling his chain
wrestling from Dagestan let's go back to
that so that fourth and fifth round I
can see scoring for magamed the 10 8 in
the fifth
yeah depending score you know it's rare
they give out 10 8 these days but
apparently they were chomping at the pit
to give out some 10 8. um I don't have
the fourth attending at the fifth ten
eight but I thought John there's an
argument he won the first three rounds
that first round's a little dicey really
the fight is predicated off that first
round if you're gonna give those 10 8
later in the fight
um again nobody was robbed nobody was
robbed
um you have more of an argument that
magumed won that fight but I'm okay with
the draw I know it's not what we wanted
I know it sucks come on here today and
for you guys at home that paid whatever
it is 79.99 for the HD pay-per-view that
you didn't get a winner
but it draws okay and I don't agree with
data going I never want to see that
fight again they're just not a good
stylistic matchup I disagree I think
there were some nerves I think there was
some feeling out I think
um you make that a Fight Night Main
Event and I think the next fight will be
much better I think they're both gonna
see what they did well in that fight
adapt and I would love to see a rematch
I don't like when guys go to draw and
there's no conclusion later on that
doesn't make much sense to me
um and the chance of that being a draw
again
very very little you know you had
Woodley Thompson and for whatever reason
they're just not good dance partners
that I get Woodley's style Wonder Boys
especially Wonder Boys style right you
had that draw in the championship match
as well as more of a recent one recently
in the last what eight years at least so
that one didn't make too much sense
because Wonderboy can't change his style
and Woodley's uh counter fighter so he
had this kind of boring mismatch there
and they did it numerous times right but
with yawn magomed that one seems like if
you're gonna do a rematch out of any
Fighters that would be the one to do it
we need a clear-cut winner there so one
of them can move on you can't just say
stylist doesn't work let's move on well
they're both ranked in the top four
let's get going we need a clear-cut
winner I would book that I wouldn't have
them do anything have them recover book
them in the next fight because you
already have a fight and didn't announce
it you already have an interim light
heavyweight title
um against uh Hill and Global Tech
Sierra so I'd have them win whoever wins
that fights the winner of that pretty
easy you know pretty easy but uh no one
was robbed on Saturday night no one's
robbed You're you're your anger and your
outlash online should be directed
towards those judges who never have to
take any accountability never have to
show face never have to explain their
judging never have to explain why they
came up with these 10-8 rounds or why
they scored you know two rounds for
Patty pimlet 29-28 across the board or
why one judge had it 48 47 for yawn
they'll had it 46 48 for magamad then
one judge had it as a draw you know so
it really comes down that judge had it
as a draw
wouldn't you like a little explanation
just how they gave me those conclusions
because if the judge who gave it 4847
for yawn then the judge who gave 4648
for magmed gave us good arguing skill I
get it
but to leave us in the dark we come up
with our own theories and it it just
builds this hatred not towards the
judges which is the problem towards the
fighters
and no one wants to address the elf in
the room where
Dana will say I can't leave it up to the
judges see well no no no no no no no no
that doesn't work for me I've gone this
[ __ ] ramp before that doesn't work
for me in 2022 where a fight like Patty
pimlet and yon were going I can't leave
up to the judges hey hey stop we have to
address this you have to put some effort
into it and now I know Dana does own the
commissions but if Dana has so much
power in the UFC and uh WME Endeavor has
so much power they could shake the trees
a little bit there and hold these judges
more accountable because when Dana goes
can't even handle the judges that gives
him an out that's his escape goat I tell
you guys go for the Finish yeah man I am
turns out the guy I'm fighting happens
to be pretty [ __ ] good he's hard to
get out of there man
and judging is part of the sport for us
to say the judges flawed don't let go
the judges no that doesn't work and no
other sport would you guys accept that
and no other major sport would that be
an outlet then an escape goat to go
sorry don't leave it to the judges never
never ever in the history of
professional sports do we just
we're okay with it being completely raid
completely
false it's just a lot of their decisions
they make no [ __ ] sense and they we
don't hold any we don't hold them to to
be accountable for it we just go ah what
can you do and then we hate on the
fighter it's not a pathway problem it's
not a yawn problem it's not a magomed
problem it's not Jared Gordon prom it's
a UFC judging problem
it's based off again it's based off this
old school
way of judging a boxing match and they
manipulate it and kind of tried to mold
it into the UFC and it doesn't work for
us
but yet we keep and the definition of
insanity is keep making the same mistake
and not changing that's what DFC has
been doing
since the dawn of time since the start
of the UFC in 1993 in Denver Colorado
we've done the same [ __ ] over and
over and over
and the only thing we get is can't leave
it up to the judges
what
what that makes no [ __ ] sense
but let's throw all the hate at the
fighters have nothing to do with it and
you know because we're so conditioned to
go
should he judging part of the game
and we just do nothing about it that is
the definition of insanity
yet we put up with it as fans as
Fighters as managers as owners of the
UFC we put up with it nobody is doing
anything to change the judging criteria
in the UFC we just all go
part of the game
it's mind-blowing to me it is the
definition of insanity look it up you
keep making the same mistake over and
over the and it's just on repeats on
this Loop
and yet who suffers from it the fighters
that you'd have to pay
they get knocked down in the rankings
Dana White holds it against them even
though he knows the judge is awful his
escape code is don't leave up to the
judges get him out of there well
Monument's pretty [ __ ] good Jared
Gordon's pretty [ __ ] good I'm trying
my best
sometimes I get those guys are just too
good to get out of there at this level
at the skill level the UFC in every
division from 1 to 50 all of them are
[ __ ] talented men and they're tough
to get out of there but the Escape guard
is
don't leave to the hands of the judges
when's it not going to work for you guys
when are you going to quit reading
headlines of these [ __ ] Outlets who
throw all this hate towards the fighters
when are you going to start getting
smart about things and start
start giving that attention to the
[ __ ] judging they're the problem not
Patty not yawn not Darren till not
deporia not Bryce Mitchell the judging
but I've heard nothing about them those
individuals we know who they are those
individuals we just give them that out
judges are going to judge
imagine in any other sport if you just
allowed that you would never if the
Dallas Cowboys were screwed over by
horrible judging can't leave it up to
the rafts
what
that makes sense and no other sport with
the fan base except that only in
fighting and no other sport do they
accept that
don't go to the judges
well [ __ ] man I they're here to do a job
how how's the judging not changed over
the years
we clearly have a problem yet we just
keep
dealing with that's all good that's
judging man
do something about it
do something about it but again watch
the media then paint this nerve how bad
of a bad person Patty is and they're not
going to allude to the fact the real
problem what everyone should be focused
on is the judging the judging is the
issue Patty has nothing to do with the
judging
boxing different world it's corrupt
there's money play there judges are
bought off the UFC I don't think it's
that case I I think what's going on with
UFC right now and just call what it is
the UFC's had some they're taking some
else lately when when you look at the
the crowds the John is it John Krause
James Crouse Krouse look at the James
Krause thing with The Insider betting
you know guys taking Falls that's a
black guy that makes us question the
judging and the the Criterion stuff like
that
um you look at what's going on now with
the judging with Patty pimlet and John
that's a problem they've taken a lot of
black guys lately
yet they do nothing about it it's their
biggest problem so now you're going to
see the UFC machine defend Patty you see
the rest of the media say that Patty you
know that Dana you know was paying off
these judges and all that so you're
gonna let's see who you're gonna see
this war this marketing War
you can see this marketing War it's me
interesting I would bet on the UFC when
it comes to marketing but you're gonna
see a war
that we wouldn't have to deal with this
if both of them the the MMA media these
high-level journalists and the UFC if
they focus on judging and making some
changes so we just don't go can't leave
the hands of the judges that would solve
all our problems but nobody wants to
focus on the problem that you want to
take each other down you want to [ __ ] on
Patty you want to [ __ ] on yon and magmet
you guys want to do that you want [ __ ]
on Dana the problem is none of this the
problem is the judging every single time
every [ __ ] weekend we have a problem
you guys keep going back to the well and
that is the definition of insanity you
nothing to change it all you do is get
online and complain about it you do
nothing to change it
I don't get it
what do you got Jen
alrighty I'll tell you the next fight
I'd like to see for Darren till and I
don't think they're gonna cut them
they're not gonna come because that
fight was fight of the night
um and thank God there until it gets
another chance uh shabazzi and Darren
tells a fight
and remember they pushed chabasian
because of his coach and his connections
to admin they pushed him as too much too
soon but now he's back on the path
different coaching different management
he's getting back in there I'd love to
see him against a guy like Darren till I
think he beats there until
but shabazzian and Darren tell is a hell
of a fight big step up for shabazzian
even though it's not vintage during till
big win
big feather in his cap
all right so
Patty pimblet had a podcast with Dana
White a couple weeks ago and then they
went off on Arrow and Juani yeah they're
saying something like
it seems like more of a just
misunderstanding but Patty pemblitt is
his uh manager was expecting to get paid
for the interview yeah I've had to deal
with Patty pillman's managers great dude
one of the best managers in the game he
actually runs cage uh for cage Warriors
out there which
if you're not familiar with them you
know bisbane came out there Hardy came
out of there
um Conor came out of there now you have
Patty Pam with some other names
um
you know what's the heavyweight stud
y I took NyQuil last night my brain is
probably as [ __ ] Hospital came out of
there so there's a lot of savage that
come out there it's by far by far the
biggest promotion Europe and they create
Superstars that's what they do
so I you know I took the squad down to
San Diego to do a food truck with Patty
and I met this gentleman and first thing
he tells me is you know how big of a
piece of [ __ ] Ariel is and uh I've seen
me and Ariel have our differences and
Ariel talks about living in people's
heads
you don't hear a lot about me and uh me
going after Ariel you hear him bring me
up on numerous shows
I'll never understand that
um but that is who he is but I don't
engage with that stuff I I don't engage
with the gossip and stuff like that and
I don't know what went on there but he
from what I heard what he and again I
didn't hear this from Ariel I heard this
from one side so I always take you with
a grain of salt he goes uh we can't
stand Ariel we were in uh I forget where
they're at they're in London doing
something uh we had something lined up
and Patty's been getting paid to do
things and then Aaron goes come do my
interview and they're like Well we'd
have to leave this one they're paying us
so if you pay us a nice area just blew
up on about he doesn't pay and stuff
like that and he's like so [ __ ] Ariel
I'm like
I mean all right you know so there seems
to be an issue there so
um I think the other reason why Patty's
getting hate
is because he's he's Dana White's guy
right he's the next guy and him and Dana
goes on the show and him and Dan are are
you know chummy and they're boys
you know I always correlate doc to
Shawshank Redemption you want to be Andy
Dufresne right you want to be the guy
that people root for when you're friends
with the warden who runs the Asylum when
he runs the the prison nobody roots for
that guy so that's not doing any favors
and I I don't think Patty cares maybe he
does the uh Optics there but to have
Dana on you guys are you have this
common enemy in Ariel hawani and I don't
know all the background to Ariel and
Dana I don't obviously mean they really
have had issues that doesn't mean Hero's
a bad guy I do think he's the best Jonas
we have I've said that since day one
even when we're beefing Lou Thomas is up
there you know there's a few got tip of
the spare guys Arrow Luke Thomas some
other dudes
so I don't know the the depth of Ariel
and Dana I know
if Dana has a hit list if he's off that
show uh Billy Madison I remember the guy
going to assassinate people and he has
the lipstick on they cross out the names
I'm probably
top five on that list but I'm I'm I'm
lower than Ariel he if he hates anyone
more than me it'd be Ariel right so when
Patty and Dana get together and have
this common enemy it brings Patty and
Dana closer together and you're not
going to get any fan votes off that that
I think that's where a lot of the hate
comes from from Patty when you when your
Chums and your buddies and your mates
with Dana White and what he represents
for a lot of guys whether you're right
or wrong you know you're not going to
get any brownie points there you're
getting a lot a lot more hate no one
likes to see the prisoner with the ward
and chumming it up getting extra snacks
getting you know these breaks that so
that's where a lot of the hate comes
from so I didn't see this this was
Ariel's latest comments what I was
saying was uh well so who's saying that
so who's patty patty says what I was
saying was Zero wanted me to do a a paid
gig you don't want me to not do a paid
gig to do something for free with him
that and that's what the manager told me
Patty said and somehow people are
defending him that's it simple as I
don't even really need to talk about
anymore that's just a fact comes out
with this false narrative and said it
didn't bother him an hour and 15 minute
video about it so we know it's bothering
him he's actually lied and tried to make
himself look good I guess Ariel showed
receipts though that's always dicey yeah
so there's a memo where you know you can
actually do like a voice memo as a
message so Patty's like hey I'm going to
be in New York or whatever so if you
want to do something let me know so
Ariel took that as you know an interview
right but now Patty's saying that no
just he wanted to go get a coffee or eat
or something like that but he's and
because he considered him a friend but I
guess he now he considers oh he says
area doesn't consider him a friend
interesting but he considers aerial
friend okay
um we'll address this after the fight me
and me manager don't you worry you got
all this stuff there he's gonna look
like an idiot pigment then addressed The
Voice much that uh Hawaii shared on the
air in which it appeared that pimlet was
asking to meet face to face for
interview in 2021
the voicemail when I said do you want to
meet uh didn't mention interview
pimlet said to have to like have a drink
or have something to eat as a friend but
he obviously never saw me as a friend
where I saw him as a friend he only saw
me as a pound sign in dollar signs I
just wanted it I was just comp yeah
comedy them uh Pima has won five
straight
gotcha yeah I mean you know it's like a
real housewives of the UFC that's what
this is this drama so I really don't
give a [ __ ] uh ill you know what he does
he does a lot of Fighters I have to deal
with a lot of Fighters there's gonna be
drama you know it's just what uh the
internet loves and
I think if Patty and Ariel just it was I
hate when people aired out on their
shows obviously again for clicks and
Views it's a good thing to do that these
guys like to do this stuff but this
should be a conversation man-to-man this
should be a conversation person and they
would squash this and arrow will be able
to use him and he'd be able to use
Ariel's platform which is massive in our
sport so
um it only hurts both of them and let's
say Patty comes on to become champ the
same five fights he's fighting for a
world title and Ariel's missing out on
that that's not good they should squash
this also Patty doesn't need to put
energy into this into a journalist
like this is what Ariel does you know
it's gonna be a tough tough fight and
Ariel again watch the headlines on MMA
fighting which Aerials and codes with
those headlines are going to be favored
towards Patty they paint a lot of the
narrative for the MMA fan base so it's
just there's no upside to this for for
Patty now I'm not saying bow down to
Ariel but doesn't sound like this is
much of a thing okay so we had a paid
gig and the area wanted you to skip it
to do his you said no you have to pay me
here he goes I don't pay for interviews
that's that should have been a
conversation to make Arrow a bad guy to
make Patty a bad guy Patty's supposed to
get compensated off doing another
interview and now to defend Patty I know
it's for a fact
we didn't pay him but I do know when we
reached out to him my teammates out to
him his manager goes what's the talent
fee there's no Talent fee we don't pay
anyone because okay all good just so
you're aware Patty usually gets paid but
he's a fan
and you I know you support him so we're
gonna do it okay
if you would tell us I don't know Tang
jeez I'm like pass we don't have the
budget doesn't make much sense as much
like Patty big interview for us but
um it's just not the way this any sport
really works unless you're doing like a
a GQ piece or something outside of the
MMA field this only builds your brand
you know so to defend Ariel too it's
like now you pay for an interview
and patients should just be like all
right well let's do it next time or
maybe later or the next day I don't know
what schedule is like but hey I don't
miss out on whatever was 20 G's just do
your interview I respect you I'd like to
do it but I'm going to do this one then
I can come to you or I'm gonna do this
one up let's reschedule this is easy to
figure out but again it it's this cool
thing to hate on Patty now right Patty
and I'm sure online Patty's a liar and
arrow has receipts Patty's like no you
guys are off you know
Real Housewives of UFC
all right so there are rumors that Conor
McGregor or there's rumors that Dana
White was saying Conor McGregor versus
Michael Chandler will be next he was
like confirmed I saw online huh but it's
not he said he never said that it's just
the way the question was asked and how
he said he goes well if Conor was
fighting right now then that would be
the you know something like that could
happen but he's not fighting right now
he's not fighting around who knows where
channel is at when Conor finally comes
back we don't know when Conor's coming
back that'd be a great fight makes sense
all right
uh Luke Connor's favorite in that fight
too
um
a little bit more about James cross so
he remember he he was also a coach and
owned a gym so now he sold his ownership
part of it his share of the gym yeah and
uh since all this stuff happened
remember Alberta and there's another
place that that wouldn't take bets
anymore now Alberta is taking bets again
because the UFC actually you know
suspended James and cut that guy Derek
Minor
yeah
um I have a buddy who's really close to
this situation with James Krauss and you
know the betting stuff I just we haven't
even heard the worst of it apparently it
gets pretty dicey it's like straight up
like insider trading guys taking Falls
or it's very dicey crazy and then I
remember I think it was on aerial show
they're saying like James Krauss had
this membership club on his on his
Discord to you know talk about for
better bets yeah and I guess the fee was
like 50 bucks a month to like 2 000 a
month and he had like over 50 something
or 500 something patreon for betting
yeah but that's so much freaking money
if I'm James Krause it's right off in
the sunset keep doing that
did and I don't know it's me just asking
a question was the reason he was so good
at the spelling making so much money
because he was giving picks based off
inside knowledge of guys being heard we
don't know that's taking a fall or was
he actually good at picking fights MMA
is very tough to battle Yeah actually I
think it was like over 2 000 subscribers
but that's all gone now too oh why he
just cut it off I guess maybe that's
part of the punishment I don't know I
already I heard this game get dicey yeah
it's already getting I heard crazy
urging you get dark
from this guy who's very close situation
who knows if he's right but I do trust
him
I'm talking prison time if what he's
talking about yeah yeah spicy stuff we
haven't heard the last of it
uh this is just pretty cool so Raul
roses Junior won on Saturday and his
hero was Robbie Lawler and I guess
Lawler's supposed to fight on that card
but he was injured yeah so then
oh it's so cool yeah that's his hero and
then hold on a second here so this is
Lawler
talking to him no one's more
disappointed than me to not be fighting
this weekend would have been nice to
meet you this weekend
um if you're ever in South Florida we
can train together good luck this
weekend that kid is a talent too yeah
Savage that showed up for his first
fight look at his cake 10 years old when
I was 10 my cake was um
and pissed me off it was a junior sale
because I love footballers Junior sale
getting tackled by Steve Atwater
for the Broncos I told my mom said the
two defensive players mom they wouldn't
be on the field at the same time
she was just eat the cake I got I know
but I need to understand that makes
sense
it's in the details ball they won't be
on the field at the same time I like
both of them they're both my favorite
football players at the time but you
[ __ ] it up
you [ __ ] it up it's been Junior Seau
tackling John Elway that would have made
me happy strata best though shout out to
Albertsons Aurora
of I live
all right uh so this is
I guess uh Bruce Buffer when guaranto is
walking out of the cage I saw that
during chill knows the game right so
even though I had a great performance he
got hurt again and keeps getting hurt
which isn't helping things he's gonna be
outside line for another hot second with
a torn ACL yeah when he tells Bruce
Buffer I tore my Ico on Bruce goes you
want me to tell him that he goes no well
you know damn well that's gonna get out
you know no he just says like uh he is
no he doesn't he doesn't know for a fact
that's why yeah he was I think he told
him I see on Bruce because you want me
to tell him that he was no
okay well this camera's everywhere in
the mic picked up everywhere and he told
Bruce Bufford and he's all mic'd up
all right so I had no idea the Korean
zombie was supposed to fight but I guess
he was supposed to fight Giga chikaze
and and Seoul Jesus Christ right not a
great fight from real zombie but
apparently he
messed up his shoulder again the Supreme
gods do him a solid they've been a tough
fight for him
all right oops there's another one I
don't know how old this interview is but
I'll just play it for you
it's just about a interviewer and Dana
White says middleweight Championship or
Conor McGregor at anfield uh sold out
crowd and and we can watch again which
would you prefer
another way title Conor McGregor's a
lightweight
two weeks below for me
yeah what would it happen you're not
willing to drop down um let's the reason
I mentioned anfield is because obviously
I know he's two weeks below me
that makes sense no the guy just did
whatever he went right yeah it was
stupid
um
this is a quick one as well Muhammad
said that he he signed a match with Leon
uh Edwards
for title shot let's see you go see them
all right I just saw him waiting for
Leon and then Leon said this shut up you
bought me ain't getting a title shot
who's the bum begging for a fight with a
guy in a three fight losing streak
oh he's referring to Mazda
he slapped you in your own country and
you didn't do nothing get over it
yeah I wish they'd give Muhammad the
title so they'd be sick
this is a another quick one Dustin
Poirier he had a really bad foot staph
infection staff yeah yeah thank God he's
out of the hospital back and forth and
Alex is awful look at that Frankenstein
foot yeah that Wednesday Adam's foot
but yeah he was able to make it to his
daughter's Play Good Man shouted
disemporary and you saw this too uh when
Conor McGregor I guess Joe Rogan on his
podcast said something like if Conor
pissed in a cup right now it would melt
something he saw the cup it melt the cap
and then Connor responded with this he
was Joe looks like his piss melts his
knickers in this company that long and
never took a fight uh oh Taekwondo
Champion or competition call the cops
yeah
um
you know a lot of this it's tough and
trust me I understand it happens to me
too when you're joking around and people
take it as word and think you're hanging
on the guy like he's talking about I
think plays more dates and you realize
Rogan was a comic before he's a UFC
commentator he's on you know uh news
radio or before he was on
um Fear Factor he was a comic so his
first defense when if anything's to make
light of situation you know make some
funny comments about it and then
unfortunately it gets taken out of
context people think he's serious
there's a funny ass comment and then
Conor sees it I'm sure people tagging
him all this [ __ ] and then he fires off
at him you know that's how this works
all right I'm not sure what this one is
Connor don't give a [ __ ] though he just
fires off and then deletes the Tweet
yeah is that it yeah that's it uh you
got a good fight night this Saturday you
got fight night uh where are we at here
we're just fighting like that Jen
let's see
Fight Night in Vegas Apex Center you got
Sean Strickland Jared Cannon there uh
for Sean Strickland he wins this one
he's right back in the queue and I know
he wants a rematch with pierra
um so for Sean Strickland this is a
Redemption fight I think you're gonna
get a much better version of Sean
Strickland Fury camner is a Savage but I
do think John Strickland gets it done I
won't pick against Sean Strickland he
mentally that's his Advantage I think he
learned from that Pierre fight and uh he
knows what's on the on the table if you
were to win this one so
um I think Sean Strickland redeems
himself you have Armin fighting as well
in the co-main event great freaking
Fighter
um yeah solid car Drew Dober Bobby
Green's a fun one
uh Jake Matthews is fighting Julian
Marquez
said uh Madoff is a the next big thing
in bantamweight so make sure you pay
attention to that good card salt card I
love the main event Sean Strickland dear
can there I'll take Sean Strickland that
one though and of course I'm taking
Armin over demare
cool is that it that's it all right kids
um that's it that is it your boy has a
food truck today uh last food truck we
do with Frankie Edgar that was a fun one
we have a bunch of guests coming up uh
we have TJ Dillashaw talking about his
retirement that stuff I gotta shoot that
later today with the the recent retired
TJ Jill shot today and um closing out
the year hard it's been a it's been a
fun interesting year start my own
network it's been a lot of work and I'm
excited for next year and we're just
getting started here thick boy I can't
thank you guys enough for being part of
it and uh helping us out and showing
support and subscribing and liking and
listening to everything we do so shout
out to you guys uh shout to everyone
about a ticket on the road during the oh
he thick tour I have a bunch of more
tour dates coming up the only one post
right now is I'm in Tampa I think end of
January so um that's the first one and
we'll have some more news for the 2023
tour coming up
um
we got everything at thickboy.com the
tiger thick award-winning nectar we got
the new golden hour uh Christmas
sweatshirts on there the uh we just um
replaced I'm sorry restocked the MLB
quality thick boy jerseys and hoodies
and the hats on there so you go to thick
boy.com for all that
um that's it man thank you guys for
tuning in big food trucks coming up can
close out the year
um in a great way and thanks for
listening thanks for watching be nice to
each other all right love you guys I'm
out if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding